we have an update on Ian Smith in New
Jersey gym owner we introduced you to
who's battling the governor of that
state for the right to earn a living
Tracy Gallagher has the very latest on
that hey Tracy hey Tucker the owners of
a Tillis gym in South Jersey vowed to
open every day this week regardless of
the consequences Monday they were given
a citation Tuesday they were cited and a
gym member was arrested for violating
the order today the owners ian smith and
frank trombetti were charged with making
a public nuisance and it gets worse
a police camera is now taking pictures
of members as they leave the gym and our
South Jersey Fox affiliate says police
then follow the members and issue them
citations today governor Phil Murphy was
asked about the gym watch inside no
ventilation close contact is a hard nut
to crack we're just not there yet you're
not there yet on gyms we're not there
yet on indoor dining do we want to be
there will we get there please god yes
but weren't they late today the owners
of a Tillis gym released a statement
claiming 45 minutes after the governor
spoke the toilets in the gym started
back flowing sewage and the gym had to
shut down for the day
Tucker amazing what a saga trace
Gallagher thanks so much for that